ceci est un smartphone ceci est la boîte
du smartphone ça ça ça c'est mes notes
et ça c'est un casque voilà tout on a
besoin aujourd'hui pour parler justement
due au port et nos jeux pour le pape a
dû au port hainaut avec le zoom x dit ça
on en parlera dans quelques temps dans
une famille dès maintenant à vous
abonner si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
comme ça vous saurez tout sur le
smartphone avec le zoom x 10 2 au pot là
va parler du réno le réno tout court pas
si tout pour que ça alors il ya aussi le
réno 5g ça on n'en parle pas ici je vis
en france la 5g n'est pas arrivé on
serait en suisse notamment peut-être sur
mon pote listant parier là on pourrait
parler du au port et no 5 g en france ça
ne sert à rien donc je vous parle de ce
modèle a apprécié vous n'êtes pas en
france on peut aussi parler du au port
innocent mais bon bref passons à gauche
[Musique]
le au port et nous il était présenté il
ya quelques temps à zurich en suisse
justement un smartphone qui est
vachement intéressant qui pourrait être
un petit peu effacée par le haut pour
région avec le zoom x 10 mais pas tant
que ça parce qu'il fait vachement de
choses il les fait très bien
il est sympa il est beau il est d
intégrer mais la meilleure chose c'est
encore de le montrer en gros plan dans
la famille des smartphones à moins de
500 euros je demande le au port et nos
beaux produits
bien bien fini surtout très bien fini
regardez là je sais pas si vous l'avez
vu la façon dont la caméra est intégré
ce qui sait qu'elle est complètement en
un seul bloc
elle ne dépasse pas alors après il ya
des personnes qui aiment et qui n'aime
pas ça c'est une petite bille envers ce
qui fait que lorsque vous le posez votre
smartphone vous avez toujours voyez
cette petite bascule qui sait ici de
côté ou de l'autre
à côté de ça se trouve c'est vachement
bien parce que ça évite justement que
cette partie là haut niveau de
l'appareil photo risque de se rayer
comme vous avez la petite bascule là
vous avez des frottements qui sont bien
plus haut ou bien plus bas donc un
appareil photo qui ne va jamais skié à
moi que vous alliez avec une pierre
claver chercher vraiment les histoires
donc ça s'est vraiment bien un
smartphone qui est vraiment parfaitement
bien intégré légèrement incurvé avec un
dos en verre très doux très sympa alors
qu'on s'est quand même de protéger ses
biens mais c'est un petit peu glissant
si vous voulez éviter la déconvenue
mais telle une coque de protection seul
côté ici vous avez votre bouton pour
venir l'allumé pour l'éteindre un grand
standard vous retrouver en bas un haut
parleur mono qui situent juste là de la
recharge en usb type c'est votre micro
votre prise jack
ça c'est qu'on est la prise jack vous
avez sur le côté ici les boutons de
volume vos tiroirs de cartes sim
ici non extensible uniquement de la
carte sim et votre micro pour la
réduction de bruit un tout petit haut
parleur qui est incrusté juste ici là
vous avez l'appareil photo avant qui
vient sortir je loue tout à l'heure et
voilà c'est tout il est bien estime dans
la main ce smartphone que vous avez
utilisé à deux mains par contre pas à
une seule main à main que vous ayez des
matchs géant mais sinon il faut utiliser
à demain vous avez si le capteur
d'empreintes digitales
c'est pas le plus rapide du monde mais
dans l'absolu il fait son boulot on est
sur du milieu de galles il déverrouille
assez rapidement je pose mon doigt pour
l'essai du capteur optique le smartphone
en lui-même est cool fonde sur color os
papa rentre dans des tailles jour nuit
sur coup leur os sono est ce qui est
sympa on peut faire plein de choses avec
il est basé sur android 9 pas il est
bien il est sympa il est mignon
de ce point de vue là ça va parfaitement
bien pour un dock un design
irréprochable signé au pot sur ce modèle
pour continuer sa progression dans le
milieu de gamme avec un produit hyper
sexy je sais pas si vous l'avez essayé
mais en tout cas je me suis régalé avec
je vais vous montrer ya un point qui est
vraiment très très très très sympa un
point très fort
c'est l'écran on a un écran de 6,4
pouces de diagonale avec une résolution
de 2340 par 1080 pixels format 19 points
5/9 et une dalle de 402 pixels par pouce
ici vous avez pas d'un coach c'est un
seul écran grand écran d'un grand bloc
on voit que les grands écrans comme ce
havre de plus en plus se démocratiser on
retrouvera bientôt des caméras carrément
cachés sous les troncs complètement
invisible saas avec la tendance qui va
développer fin 2019 2020
pour l'instant on en est pas encore là
pour l'instant on est déjà arrivé dans
cette très grand écran là avec une
caméra ailerons de requins qui fait
parfaitement bien la faire
l'écran est très lumineux la qualité
sympa elle va parfaitement bien pour
regarder des films pour des séries pour
ce que vous voulez pour des jeux pour
naviguer sur internet pour faire pas
tout ce que vous voulez ça va
parfaitement bien en plus à la vente
vous avez un congo et agressif en termes
de sécurité ça va c'est vrai que c'est
un produit qui sent la robustesse et ça
c'est vraiment un point que j'adore avec
ce produit c'est que on sans parler
forcément du fait d'avoir dû corning
gorilla glass cinq ans ning gorilla
glass 6 il sent la robustesse on se dit
pas que c'est un produit qu'on va casser
directement leur attention néanmoins
smartphone envers smartphone phrase il
protège avec une coque
c'est vrai que l'expérience multimédia
là dessus avec un grand écran comme ça
ça change absolument tout moi je suis
vraiment très très très très grand fan
le fait de ne pas voir dans le proche
orient ne pas avoir de guildes auront de
ce que vous voulez qui peut aller que
certains smartphones mais c'est vrai que
quand on peut s'en passer c'est quand
même vachement mieux alors voyais pas
venir croquer un peu dans votre image
mais a tout de suite profité d'une
immersion qui vont vraiment superbe paul
vi multimédia autre point vous avez un
haut parleur mono ici crash franchement
très fort la qualité est pas
complètement dingue
les biens communs du son ce que je
m'approchais justement haut parleurs
c'est je le trouve un petit peu trop
médium médium un peu grave alors ça fait
parfaitement la faire lorsque vous êtes
dans un nous il ya un petit peu de bruit
environnant pas énormément sinon ça ne
marche pas n'oubliez pas qu'au local que
sur un smartphone
eh bien on entend c'est pas mal la
qualité est pas complètement live si
vous voulez monter en qualité ce que je
vous conseille c'est bien évidemment de
prendre un casque avec une prise jack
parce que oui mesdames messieurs sur ses
smartphones vous avez une prise jack qui
est conservée pourquoi une prise jack me
direz vous bassine
question positionnement stratégique hop
on part du principe que les personnes
qui vont acheter un smartphone à moins
de 500 euros ont pas forcément investir
dans un casque bluetooth qui va coûter
un coût plus cher voire carrément
cherche on veut de la bonne qualité
après je sais il ya des casques
bluetooth qui sont pas hyper hyper
onéreux mais l'idée c'est de se dire que
à ce moment là la personne n'aura
peut-être plus un casque avec une prise
jack pourra l'utiliser il y en aura pour
toutes les bourses
cette prise jack et dans l'absolu pas
trop trop mal vous avez quand même du
volume par contre je trouve que le rendu
et manque un peu de pression dans les
aigus on reste quand même dans un
spectre un peu médium médium basse on
n'a pas beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
précision à côté de ça il ya du volume
sonore une fois de plus je lis et je
leur dis attention poussée passions trop
fort pour ne pas vous rendre sourd ou
sourde bon joueur et je surveille ses
grands écrans quand même c'est tout
autre chose c'est vraiment sympa c'est
hyper agréable hyper confortable et ça
change vraiment la donne
alors là dessus en plus vous avez un
snapdragon 710 1 qui marche plutôt bien
ah bon sens j'ai commencé par péter ma
bagnole si giga de ram 256 giga de
stockage non expansé beauce envié de
tous les côtés on est sur une machine
qui marche quand même ce groupe
relativement bien on n'est pas sur le
smartphone le plus performant on n'est
pas sur son album 855 les voiliers pour
jouer à des jeux comme ça on n'a
absolument aucun ralentissement je suis
une vraie brel on n'a aucun
ralentissement
c'est quelque chose qui est assez fluide
qui marche bien le smartphone en plus ne
change pas ça c'est aussi un poids qui
est hyper hyper hyper hyper appréciable
je dois reconnaître que je suis assez
mauvais quand même je suis par un très
très bon joueur je pense que vous
l'aurez deviné on a une grosse batterie
de 3750 millan terreur alors c'est pas
la plus grosse batterie qu'on puisse
retrouver en or une plus grosse batterie
dans le haut pour hainaut avec le zoom x
10 mai déjà comme il est là trouve que
l'autonomie est vraiment banque veut
garder un jour ni sans problème deux
jours si vous êtes un peu moins gourmand
pour mende ça dépend bien évidemment de
vous vous le recharger en 1h20 1h30 ça
va ça fait la faire il a du bluetooth
5.0 du nfc pour les paiements
dématérialisés ou pour tous les pass
navigo et compagnie il n'a pas de
certification ip68 ip67 il n'est pas du
tout certifié tout simplement à cause de
cette petite caméra en aileron de requin
c'est strictement impossible aujourd'hui
de venir le certifier à cause de ça à
côté de ça je pense qu'il n'y aura
absolument aucun problème si toutefois
il rencontre de l'eau ça va plutôt bien
se passer et en plus cette petite caméra
britpop
des cas de la chute alors en tout de
suite directement pourquoi c'est plutôt
sympa maintenant dernier point et pas
des moindres c'est la partie photo vidéo
vous avez un double module photo à
l'arrière capteur principal de 40 8
mégapixels c'est la sony mx 5 186 j'en
ai déjà parlé
elle prend des photos en 12 mégapixels
par des fois en gros l'idée c'est
qu'elle va prendre quatre gros pixels
pour faire un seul et même grand pixels
donc on passe de 48 mégapixels à 12
mégapixels
si vous voulez né en moto 2 48 milliards
celle vous pouvez il vous suffit d'aller
dans les paramètres de l'appareil photo
par défaut en 4/3 ça c'est 12 mégapixels
vous avez aussi le 4/3 en 48 mégapixels
bon très clairement comme ça ça me
sortira des photo 12 mégapixels qui
iront parfaitement bien à mon avis vaut
mieux rester comme il est d'origine
on a une optique principal qui ouvre à f
1.7 tandis que la deuxième capteur 5
mégapixels ouvre à f 2.4 sera là
uniquement pour le mode portrait pour
les faits évoqués il ya rien de bien
bien dingue de ce côté là et vous avez
une caméra ailerons de requins qui
situent juste là elle c'est une salle
zinga pixels qui ouvre à f 2.0 pour mal
côté ailerons de requins je trouve ça
assez rigolo un sas où ça se remet
rapidement vous l'ouvrez vous le farmers
0,8 seconde c'est une donne au pot j'ai
l'impression que ça mais un tout petit
peu plus de temps entre moment vous
décidez vous appuyez vous appuyer que ça
se fasse
bon faut compter quand même une seconde
une seconde nerfs des appuis obstacle à
l'ouverture c'est plus facile à
fermeture ça met un peu plus de temps
bon c'est pas vraiment hallucinant après
le rendu photo est aussi vraiment de
bonne qualité alors ça dépend bien
évidemment des conditions qui vous
montre quelques photos
là vous êtes sur un plat typiquement
bavarois s'étaient à munich le week-end
dernier
voyez je voudrais même relativement de
détails lorsque vous donnez nous sommes
un petit peu dans l'image
quand vous avez beaucoup de lumière ça
marche très très bien gardé ce ciel là
on devine bien les couleurs les nuages
pareil sur les extérieurs il y avait un
bout de soleil derrière rien qu'est
crâne et il ya un bon traitement
logiciel qui est fait derrière de la
part de hauts potelets ya un peu moins
de lumière la qualité et moins au rendez
vous c'est un petit peu un petit peu
matin c'est vraiment là où on voyait la
faiblesse sur ce smartphone sur les
conditions de faible luminosité mais dès
que vous avez de la lumière il marche
parfaitement bien et n'a brillé sur la
photo de nuit comme ça j'aime beaucoup
aussi le rendu je trouve que il ya un
bon boulot qui est fébrile au niveau des
normaliens derrière c'est pas cramé ça
marche bien et là par contre voyez dès
qu'on arrive dès qu'on va résoudre un
peu dans l'image tout de suite le rendu
est vraiment horrible le zoom numérique
est vraiment très mauvais là dessus je
vous le recommande pas c'est vraiment
pour moi ce qui est bien le différencier
du
opont raynaud avec le zoom x 10 c'est
que lorsque vous voulez aller chercher
du détail allez zou d'un petit peu même
si c'est un zoom x 10 hybride
il marche parfaitement bien il vous
avait pas cet effet un peu on va pas se
mentir un peu pourri lorsque vous allez
venir zoomer avec le port et nous tout
simplement parce qu'il n'est pas fait
pour ça chaker roland-garros
le rendu est vraiment hyper hyper hyper
qualitatif une fois de plus avec son
zoom x jce
c'est vraiment pas terrible on a que du
pixel de partout c'est vraiment une
image qui est horrible si vous voulez
faire vous pouvez le faire mais je vous
le déconseille fortement en pleine
luminosité
le rendu est vraiment vraiment vraiment
vraiment top
je trouve de ce point de vue a en tout
cas au pot a vraiment fait un excellent
boulot avec ce smartphone elle a donc un
produit qui se détruire les personnes
qui veulent un smartphone avec des
performances de qualité mais pas
complètement folle qui à côté de ça
seront parfaitement suffisant pour nous
trois quarts d'heure 1 90% des visages
pour des personnes qui veulent faire des
photos en plein jour qui veulent
immortaliser des souvenirs l'équipe est
pas forcément le photophone le plus
dingue avec le zoom le plus fou est allé
plus loin en termes de photos demi parce
que la grosse différence que vous allez
avoir également photo nuit c'est qu'avec
le haut pourrait nous accueillons faut
10 vous allez appuyer ça fera une photo
instantanée en condition de nuit par
contre avec le au port et nos sens le
zoom x 10 la falloir garder votre doigt
appuyé entre trois à cinq secondes
c'est tout de suite vous n'êtes pas
hyper calais hyper stabiliser ce qui
n'est jamais mon cas la photo va être
fou pas terrible et ça je vous le
recommande pas le mode portrait fait
aussi le job des tours plutôt bien il ya
un bon boulot voyait du du petit détail
là entre les doigts ou d'un peu plus de
mal quand on est sur un soc milieu de
gamme où les 60 dragonne 710 qui
marchera moins bien qu'un 855
mais ce somme toute assez correcte la
caméra celle ci fonctionne aussi plutôt
bien même si j'ai une belle tête de
vainqueur là dessus je trouve que dans
l'absolu le rendu quand même assez
qualitatif 499 euros pour un smartphone
avec un aileron de requin que je peux
venir jeter rattraper avec une caméra
qui se ferme pour moi ces bonheurs
j'aime beaucoup leur ça vous le mark il
ya une détection de la chute peut venir
ouvrir votre caméra très facilement hop
inactive ça marche bien j'aime beaucoup
ça peut faire un petit peu gadget mais
en tout cas ça montre vraiment la
volonté de
au pot de protéger son smartphone disons
s'il tombe encaisse pas la caméra on
casse rien c'est plutôt bien moi je
trouve que je trouve intéressant si vous
voulez c'est que au pot est arrivé
l'année dernière il ya un an exactement
n'est pas jour en jour mais à quelque
chose près au louvre à paris en arrivant
avec le finepix un super smartphone dans
le haut de gamme c'est un peu compliqué
on disait ok aux ponots mon petit safer
du smartphone haut de gamme il cherche à
montrer qu'ils ont on devrait savoir
faire pour après venir inonder le marché
sur le milieu de gamme et sur l'entrée
de gamme ce qui n'a pas forcément été le
cas au niveau du inonder le marché local
sont présentes ils sont présents de plus
en plus
et justement ce pourrait être un petit
peu difficile pour eux d'arriver en
terre inconnue avec un produit quand
même relativement cher face à des
mastodontes comme samsung apple et
huawei ça pouvait être compliqué pour
eux et du coup ils font une belle
progression dans le milieu de gamme avec
ceux au port est ce que c'est vraiment
cool
il ya le haut point windows une folle et
s'honore pas dans 15 jours je sais je
vous le dis je vous le redis parce que
j'ai vraiment hâte de vous en parler
j'ai tourné ça roland-garros j'ai fait
des images top j'ai vraiment hâte pas
encore parlé vous invite dès maintenant
à vous abonner fiemme dire ce que vous
en pensez de celui là qu'est ce que vous
pensez du haut forez l'eau est ce que
vous préféreriez aller sur le au port et
n'osent une fois 10 qui sera plus
puissant que tu pourras faire plus de
choses notamment des photos qui sera
fatalement plus cher voilà ce que ce
modèle le haut pour hainaut vous tente
vous plaît oui non quoi comment vous
marquez tout ça on va en commentaire et
moi je vous dis à demain gromyko sur
vous ciao